[Music]
Greetings, my rantians. Hope you all are
doing well today and welcome back to
another episode of Ano 1800. I am very,
very excited today because we're going
to be starting on a whole new set of
islands and these are given to us by
none other than Mr. major himself, the
banner designer for the Imperium. And I
am so excited to get these going. But
before we do all the, you know, talking
about the lore and all that stuff, I
just want to mention if you did happen
to come across the channel now and you
do like what we're doing here, by all
means, feel free go and check out the
channel, see if there's something that
interests you. And if you are definitely
interested, want to stick around, we'd
love to have you. The Imperium grows
very rapidly every single day, and it's
one click away if you decide to do so.
But now I want to get into the lore
behind the kingdom of
Sappin. The Kingdom of Sappin was
Lacarona's biggest ally in the border
regions. One of its islands being
directly annexed by Lacarona following a
succession crisis in the kingdom. As
such, the kingdom is made up of a bulk
of Lacarona infrastructure and fighting
capability. The Kingdom of Sapin was
also behind the Imperium's only defeat
in the border region conflict as they
successfully defended their land and
were able to ensure that Lacarona's
vanguard forces were able to flee back
into safety. Following the ceasefire,
the Kingdom of Sappin was stripped of
its capital and the aisle of Belffort
was given to the Imperium as collateral.
Although the queen has accepted Rantian
help, her people and especially the
nobility remain very divided as to the
current balance of power and some of
them straight up opposing Rantian
intervention in the region. However, our
goal is to win the hearts of the Sepini
people. We did have to do what was
necessary in order to win the war. That
that much is clear. But I did not want
it to be at the expense of nations that
were pulled into it. This nation in
particular, of whom was extremely
strong, has a very long history and is
even deeprooted with La Corona itself.
Our goal is La Corona. Our goal is not
to destroy any nation that aligns with
them because we don't know whether
they've been in any which way, shape, or
form coerced into doing so. And that is
why we are here today. Why we are going
to work to restore the kingdom of Sappin
to the best of our ability and improve
our relations with this incredible
kingdom. Naturally, we're going to face
our own challenges. That is for certain.
We don't have access directly to
Imperium supply lines. But we will make
sure that our fellow Rantium
protectorates in the region help us with
the restoration of not only the first
island that we're working on being the
island of Remo, which I'm hopefully I'm
saying that correctly, but also for
other islands that are based with the
kingdom of Sappin itself. And there are
a couple of little checkpoints and
missions and quests that we have to do.
Mainly the objectives part is the most
important for me. So now getting out of
the role play for a second. What Mr.
Major has done is has essentially when
we broach when he broached the subject
to me way back he was telling me that
there were certain bits
of tasks that he would think is really
the best way of going about winning the
hearts of the Sapini people. And I
really like that because it, you know,
obviously builds upon the lore and the
reason why we're doing this cuz I mean
in the grand scheme of
things, would the Imperium 100% want to
restore a nation that did fight it even
though we didn't see them as a true
target? Not particularly, because that
is our time and our resources. But we
want to make sure that the world is
shifting in our favor and we're going to
do this to the best of our ability. So
the main objectives here are to place
the training post in the middle of the
imp placement which is going to be right
over here. Every house and service must
be built on the water which means
something kind of similar to what we did
over here with Imperial Albahan which
they were very very impressed about that
we were able to rebuild this nation over
down here. Uh this also goes into
specific skins which I won't go over
here. We'll just talk about them when we
get to them. We need to have a
population of 500 farmers and 500
workers with specific skins for those
ones, which we will see in a moment.
Have every mine and pits running with
electricity. That should be simple for
us to do. Place at least one dream spire
in a statue of Lady Morning Star on the
island. Totally fine. No NWCU
infrastructure allowed. Sorry, Shadow.
That's that's literally right here. I
can't do anything about that, man. You
You have to fix this. I I I can't help
you out with that, buddy. and no market
stands allowed. So the little guys that
we have just as a little reminder for
everybody, the ones that we have like
right over here. So without further ado,
let's get to work because there is a lot
of stuff that we have to do and it is
going to be a doozy of a build. So first
and foremost, I do have a bunch of
images that Mr. Major has provided to me
in order to make sure that this works
properly. And I very much appreciate not
only the time but the willingness to do
so, right? It's really important. And
what I've done in the meantime is bring
over a whole bunch of resources so we
don't have to worry about it. Your
leadership hopefully we'll see that
happen here very quickly. So the very
first thing that we want to do is we
want to try to pre-plan everything. And
every airship that you see here, minus
this one, this is for another uh another
settlement that's still based with the
Kingdom of Sappin itself. These three
plus the ship that's bringing a whole
bunch of resources over from New Albian
are part of this island and only
designated for this island. So, the very
first thing I'm going to be doing is
building up this oil refinery and
shutting it off because there's no
reason for it to work. If this thing
wants to be any louder, I'm not entirely
certain. But we are going to also get
the main roads built up. And we're going
to start it off by bringing it up to
like somewhere
here. And this is going to be real
important what's coming up. It's It's
really crucial. It's really crucial.
We're going to be going over here to the
Ranty Imperium ornaments. And now I have
to find It's this one.
Awesome. The other base going banner and
banner. So pretty. So pretty. Love to
see it. It's awesome. So, in the very
middle, we are going to be putting an
administration building for land owners.
And we're going to have to increase the
population size here quite a bit in
order for this to really work. But, this
is going to be the first place for
it. I think this is not a bad spot.
Actually, you know what? Let's bring it
a little bit further up. I'm just trying
to see what would be the best placement
because there is a little hill right
over here. So, I think if we put this
thing like maybe right here, it would be
kind of okayish. Maybe. No, I I changed
my mind. I changed my mind. It needs to
be built on the
road. What the
heck? Oh, that was weird. It had to It
had to fix itself up for a second. So,
we'll put this one right over here. I
can't follow the diagram exactly as is
cuz we I did not know that there was a
freaking hill over here. But what I'm
going to do is because the road actually
does go down to here. I'm just going to
bend it and bring it down. So at least
we have our foundation set right here. I
think there will be indeed. Look at
this. Look at what the game makes me do.
There's one way to go through here with
the train tracks. And we want to get
that sorted so we at least get some oil
going right now. And I'm trying to see
as far as where the oil should go. It
should be right over on this side. So,
let's go ahead and get the oil harbor
situated as well. And I'm going to build
it right here along with its oil stores
cuz I mean this is going to be important
considering what we're going to be doing
here. Oh crap. Did Okay, it's even. It's
even. God bless. Awesome.
All right. So, that's the next step.
Then, we want to connect up the train
tracks with the oil refinery, which is
back here. And we're going to go ahead
and do the typical tactic of having the
parallel tracks, but they're going to
have to go in a particular way. Not
necessarily straight on. I don't think
it's possible, but we can try it. Uh,
let's go from back here, maybe.
Is this still connected? Yeah, I think
it is. Still is. All right, there we go.
Let's go from about
here. Might be a little bit too
much. I lied. We're going to go from
over
here. And I will try to bend it up just
so we
can bring it right past the
administration building because that is
kind of the plan
here. And I'm going to get rid of this
one.
What did did it do anything over here?
Oh, they're not connected. What the
hell? All right, now they're connected.
Great. And I'm going to leave one row in
between that's open like this and just
keep
it. Let's bring it to about here. And
then from here down, it didn't want to
connect here either. For some reason
today, it just does not want to
cooperate with me. And then in here,
we're going to connect it up with the
second side. make it look a little bit
easier in that
regard. And we're going to bring it all
the way down to here, which it doesn't
exactly line up, but it's still fine.
We're going to do it anyway. And we're
going to do the same with this. Now, the
island of Remor, hopefully I'm saying I
don't want to say it the American way.
The Remor I I will I'll say it, I guess,
in that way for now. Remor is meant to
be a bread basket region for the kingdom
of Sappin. So, naturally getting this
place built up and if we can get some
really decent trade relations going
here, that would be fantastic cuz I mean
what we're planning here is going to be
pretty substantial. Now, I have to
unfortunately do this, which is to link
up a couple of these tracks together.
Otherwise, it's going to give me that
horrid, oh yeah, parallel tracks. Yeah,
have fun with that, champ. Go ahead and
link this one up and then this one up.
And that should be pretty good. So, what
we're going to do is start this up and
that's going to be 1 second
oil. That's wonderful. And the cool
thing is when we actually colonized this
island, we were able to get the I think
it was
unifier. Yeah, I think it was unifier.
Yeah. So, plus 100 island workforce for
this. So, regardless of whether we had
any workers here at all, this is still
going to work out just fine. And I think
just based off of the uh the vibe that
I'm getting, we should go with the uh
steampunk type skins. So, let's go with
the Steam Liner. And that's the only
ones that we will see here. Now, what I
want to do is start getting to work on
the main harbor area, which is going to
be absolutely crucial. And I also do
have a little bit of
a bit of diagrams I can pull from if in
order to do so. I really love it that
you guys are are doing this. I really
do.
So, it may not be exactly how it's set
over here, but we're going to do our
best cuz the big Betty areas, we'll have
to go over. And where the hell are even
the big betties? Right over here.
Monster guns. Well, we're going to need
some soldiers over here in order for
that to work. But this is meant for one,
and this is meant for the other. So,
those are going to be the two spots
there. And then more island storage
capacity is going to be right next to it
over here. And I'm going to do the same.
I'm just going to bring it down to make
it even with this one. I think it'll be
even. Let's see. I could potentially
even put it in front, but I want to make
sure I follow the diagrams to the best
of my
ability. There we go. I think that's
pretty good for now. And just in order
to make this spot look nice, we can
either try to put another pier or
another depot right behind it. But in
this case, it's not going to fit
properly. So, I'm just going to do this.
And I'm going to cover this up with some
of the keys over here. Should be
okay. But this spot is just different
because the the way that the shoreline
is is a little bit wonky. So, we have
those and we're going to get some more
depots
going specifically to have them face
inward a little bit like
this. So, the ships should be able to
come into the main harbor area. And even
in this particular situation, we can
have some more. There are spaces in
order to have some additional depots.
Like there there can be one there. I
think if I position this a little bit
different, we can have one there, too.
But I think on over on this side, I will
just fill this out with keystreetss. And
then later on, this is a really cool
thing. Every time someone has a
suggestion and they're watching the
videos, they message me later on and
they talk about it. So then I'll know
what to do later on and fix the areas
that they want to have fixed. That's
really, really cool. Along with that, we
are going to go ahead and get the
fisheries built up. So, the fisheries. I
think what I'm going to do actually is
just hug the road
along the depot and the key over here.
My mouse wants to work. That's a whole
different story in and of itself. And
bring it out a little bit over to about
here. Going to do the same on the other
side. Uh, that does look fantastic over
there. I don't like it when it
swaps. H was going to swap at some
point, isn't it? Unless I fix it right
now. I guess I can do that. Let's see
how far it goes. We'll bring it to about
here.
Okay. And we'll bring this over to about
here. And the cool thing is because the
kingdom of Sappin has ties to La Corona
through marriage and just the longevity
of their whole, you know, relationships
and whatnot. They have some valuable
intel that they can provide to us. We
need that intel in order to get to the
new world. That's Lacarona's base
territory. We have to make sure we get
this information. And that's another
reason why we have to be on their good
graces. Let's go ahead and build up some
of the initial fisheries right over
here. So, we'll have three fisheries and
then another depot area which is going
to be right about here. And it's
literally going to be mirrored on the
other side as well. So like right there.
Uh are any of these the old town skins?
Shoot. That's brings you in, master. Uh
you need to change. You need to be this
one until we get some people actually
here. I'm probably going to stop the
production of like these two to follow
because we just don't have enough
people. So stop you nap in the hay and
stop this one. That actually looks very
cool to start off. That's for
certain. And then there's a couple more
fisheries over on this side. So, we'll
have one over here and one over here.
The airship is coming back. Love to see
it. Just trying to make sure that it
doesn't swap its skin on me. This one.
Ah, there it is. And this one. Pretty
cool. Go ahead and bring that down to
here. And bring this one down to here.
Pause you. Pause you. I'm not doing the
shift tactic because some of them can
work and that's fine. We don't need all
of them to be functioning at the moment.
So along with that, we have enough room
for more than likely ships to get in
here when they want to trade out because
not all of the goods that are going to
be sent out from this island are only
going to be via airships. And each one
of them have been named specifically by
Mr. Major. So I went ahead and did that
as well. I can't get the one all the way
back. There we go. The Venti is meant
for another island. I just I built five
just because I need to have something
that's fast and I didn't want to use the
other ones just yet until I know exactly
what to do with them. So, what we have
to do now is we need to get the harbor
area actually built up with a whole
bunch of people. And where in the heck
is the harbor city? There it is.
Awesome. What we're going to do is we're
going to start off with some base farmer
residences. And I think this is going to
look pretty nice. Hopefully, it'll work
out for
us. There's our first people over here.
I'm going to go ahead and get the
streets put up. Life is so so. All
right, hold
up. Now, now this is going to freak me
out cuz I can't put these. Where is the
marketplace? There it is. Here's the
marketplace. And we are going to swap it
to the ornate market. There we go.
That's what we like to see. Right. Right
now, I have to make sure that I get the
brick housings, which is this one. And
we're going to swap all of their skins
to the brick
housing. I think I'm going to do some
beautifification work from time to time,
like over in these little bits and
pieces over here. But we have to provide
them with all their services. So, like
we have the morning at sea, and that's
going to be pretty important. Oh, what
the heck is this? You like Oh, no.
That's for tourism. We We don't care
about that one. Oh, there are power
plants here. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So, that that kind of works. I had no
idea that was even here. Cool. Uh the
only issue is do the farmer schools
actually have
a one at sea? Oh, they do. Awesome.
Great. Love to see it. Let's put this
right over
here. And we're going to get some more
of these homes built up.
kind of hold them right
there. And then we should probably put I
have to figure out where the heck. You
know what? Let me just take this and put
it where the docklands is and city
institutions probably where the paved
streets are just so I can get to them
very
quickly because now we should be able to
get every single one of these fisheries
online. That's really important. I think
what I will also do is potentially start
bringing in some work clothes or having
them mint being made over here is
something that wasn't necessarily
discussed quite yet, but I feel just to
air on the side of caution, which I
normally do, uh, I'm going to bring them
in from another source, and that will
allow us to see the harbor area actually
at work. So, there's this ship, right?
And let's see where's a place that has a
whole bunch of work clothes that they
don't need. Maybe Sier has them. Yep,
that seems to be a decent amount. How
about we
take three instead of the max over to
the island here, which does indeed have
its own section right here. But I will
probably change its name to make it a
little bit
better. All right, what else you all
want? So, they're getting their fish in.
That's wonderful. Uh, let's see. I think
the water the water is going to have to
be something that's built on land. So
temporarily an explosion in one of your
factories. Oh, sweet
Jesus. Hey, this is great. You know what
this building is right next to it? Let
me let me just show you. It's great.
It's an effing fire station and that
happens. No one better tell me that this
is anything besides my
luck.
Guaranteed. Guaranteed. I I will I will
die on this hill. It is my luck. It
is not the game 100%. Cuz I I'm telling
you that is the best that I could
possibly build and I put it right next
to the refinery specifically for them
blowing up. But you know it it just did.
It legitimately just did. I can't do
anything else about it. You reached a
new milestone. All right. Where's the
water? Clean water pump. We're going to
put the clean water pump right about I
think maybe about here. Please don't
leave your
And then the administration is only
going to pose a little bit of a problem
because the landowners are meant to be
like right
here and we don't have enough to provide
to them quite yet in order for the
radius to expand. So, let's see what
other stuff. Okay, so the morning at
sea. We're going to have to build that
in a moment. I think I'll put this one
like maybe it's actually really cool.
Put this one like right about here. How
far does the radius
go? Oh, I mean it goes pretty far. Yeah,
that's nice. Should be getting the water
in relatively soon. And we're getting
the work clothes in. So, that's lovely.
get a couple more farmers here. So, we
have to get up to 500 farmers and we
also need to get up to 500 workers in
order to get the farms rebuilt and all
that good stuff and make it look really
nice. I think what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to copy this, but then
I'm going to tilt it on its side and
bring it like right here. And the next
one we can probably like H what can we
put in the middle there? Well, we can
pull these guys and put them over here.
This market should reach all the way
back there. But we can also have our
city institutions being the harbor
police. We can have the old town pub
skin or the old world pub skin, excuse
me. And then we are going to have a
church, which the church I don't know if
I can swap it over on this side
to the other skins that I have. Well,
actually, you know what? I feel like
this would work.
I feel like this fits their vibe, but I
I I could be wrong. I'll more than
likely check it to see what's going on.
Uh Harbor Hospital is going to be
crucial. I think I probably would want
to put this over here then cuz it's
right in the middle as opposed to the
other one. Right. Yeah, this is going to
be a better spot for it. So, we'll put
the harbor hospital right over
here. And we're going to get a road
that's going to connect these guys cuz
over in the middle here, we're going to
do some work in a moment. And then the
police station needs to I think I put
the police station like right behind the
harbor. Uh what is this thing called?
Marketplace right there. I need to
change their skins. That's really
important. Change all their skins to the
brick ones. Very pretty. And we now have
200. And well, I mean, labor pool is
definitely going up, but I'm kind of not
counting the fact that When do we start
again?
Oh, yeah. They They need a warehouse.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's That's the
thing. Where is the harbor
warehouse? Where' that
be? Not in here. I probably have passed
it multiple times before. That's
definitely not it. Wait, wait, wait,
wait. Big brain idea. New Albian has it.
It's right over here. I'm going to yink
it. I'm going to bring it right over
here cuz we're going to have to probably
position it. Yeah, let's let's position
one like right here next to the depot or
right behind it. This one over here.
We're going to have to put it maybe
here. That works. So long as I can get
to it, you know, that's the most
important
thing. And let's get some of these and
fill this out. Going to fill this out
and this side now too along with this
and
this. So our total amount of farmers
here right now are 386 rising land lush
and green. We're going to get some of
the horses now. And the horses stables
are going to be right over
here. And we're going to be expanding
upon this for sure.
So do bear this in mind. It's definitely
a work in progress. We don't have the
grain here yet, but we're going to be
working on that soon cuz all of this
island has been mapped out already. Let
me see the steampunk skin on
this. Oh, that's so
cool. That's awesome. If only all the
cars would have had the steampunk skin
with it as well. Okay, now is that
enough horses for them right now? Yeah,
it is. So, we're bringing in the
clothes. We're already producing like 20
fish over here. That's in That's insane.
You can even probably swap these out
later if we decide to get one of those
uh ridiculously powerful power plants
going here. Oh, that would be insane.
Oh, you know what we need? It's really
important. And I didn't even put this
thing down at all. Let's put down a fire
station. Yeah, we'll put it on this
side,
though. Makes it look a little bit
nicer. And then getting into
beautifification stuff. We're going to
have to utilize the Docklands one here
quite a bit. I'm just going to swap it
out with this Regal Standard. I know it
sounds like heresy, but I need the I
need the
stuff. Put that there. Can we fit in
some seating areas? No, but we can
probably put in like a
lamp. Uh, that's too large. Just fill
that out then. I'm happy that I don't
see the crates.
Okay, let's put one seating there. We'll
put another one of these over
here. Let's do this. Let's get a lamp
post there. A lamp post here. Where's a
little bit of a key? Let's grab that and
pull this. Actually, just do the middle.
There we go. Because on the sides, we
can probably just put down some like
trees like so.
And we'll get little spot to sit and
another spot to
sit. Three
entry. Very nice. Very pretty. Looking
cool. I think what we can do as well is
also build a couple of these homes
around here, too. The kingdom of Sapun
appreciates order. Order and uniformity.
So, I'm trying to do my best to make
sure that's actually
happening. Uh, that's the wrong one. We
have
to There we go. That's going to solve
that problem right there. Grabbing a
couple more homes. I'm going to put them
right about here and change their skins
immediately. So, what are we looking at
here? We're at
625 rising. Very cool. Very cool indeed.
So, we have our first little side right
over there situated and we're going to
need a lot of people here that are going
to be working like no tomorrow
guaranteed. So, bring in a whole bunch
of their other goods and services such
as like I don't know the sausages, the
bread, all that stuff. We we will do
this, but the only thing that we need to
do first is because this is a bread
basket region, we need to start working
on the farm fields. Now, in the very
middle, right, this area is designated
for the vegetable farms that are around
the administration building
because these vegetable farms will
become ridiculously powerful. And we do
have like pretty much every other one
that we can utilize over here. Actually,
we do. We have the potatoes, we have the
vegetables, we have grain, all that good
stuff. So, if we can probably work on
the administration a little bit, then we
can have probably have like total island
coverage if we get some land owners in
good spots, right? But this is too far
away, so that's not going to help them
out at all. But for the time being,
we're going to start off with the
vegetable farms. And vegetable farms are
going to start up from like probably
here. Actually, you know what? We're
going to get a small warehouse built up
first. Actually, this is a warehouse,
isn't it? I think that is a warehouse.
Yeah, it is. I totally forgot. So, let's
get the vegetable farm. I'll get one
started in a basic place like maybe
right over
here. We have the fertilizer silo. We
also have the plow barn, which I think
we're going to need some tools in order
to activate, right? Is it tools or is it
just Yeah. Yeah. So, we're going to have
to bring in some tools as
well. And then the fertilizer silo,
which is going to be right behind
it. Pretty cool. It's going to increase
the farm field
size. So, I'm just going to finish them
out with a shift tactic just to make it
look really
cool. Uh, we'll do the same over on this
side. Then get this one to here and get
these two built up. Man, I love being
able to pre-plan stuff, but holy hell, I
went out of freaking timber. Ain't that
fantastic? Love to see it. Love to see
it. And I thought I was doing so well
already. So, so well. Okay, that's now
10. No, that's
92. Let's get them over here. 96. So, we
have already satisfied one condition
being the farmer workforce limit. But
now we have to work on the workers and
getting some more of the farm fields
built up. It's already starting to look
very pretty. Uh the reason why we ran
out of a whole bunch of the uh timber is
because well I mean building all of
these is going to take a bunch. But uh
getting these ones too is also going to
be a fair amount. I'm I'm bringing in
one additional resource to the region.
And uh you see how the fertilizer barn
or fertilizer silo is actually working.
Yeah, it is because I've been also
bringing over some dunk from uh new
Albian. Yeah. Yeah, it was necessary.
Okay, it's definitely
necessary. Can we build this one? No, we
need actually to have
them. Let's see. I guess I could
pre-plan where the other ones are going
to be to start off. Let's grab this and
put it over here. I'm going to just put
it in blueprint mode for
now. And we'll get
there the barn. And we'll also get this
one over here. And then do the exact
same thing we did on the other side.
Right over here. I want to see if I can
No, I don't want to copy it. I kind of
want to mix it up from time to time. You
know, it shouldn't all look the exact
same. That's my opinion when it comes to
farm fields because even if you go and
see the real things, right? They're not
all looking the exact same. They all
have different layouts based off of the
land. And I really want to try to stick
to that. So, let's get this road all the
way over to
here. And we'll extend it like
this and get the fields positioned
around
it. Kind of just tuck it in.
Is that Max? Oh my god, that was
awesome. That's going to look really
nice. We should have a spot for an
Imperial Trade Union here as well. Where
is that other airship? You know, it's
has the funniest uh clipping issue over
in New Albian. Is it there right now?
Look, look at this. It's all the way in
the freaking
building. It's hilarious. I love it. You
love to see
it. All right. Can we fast forward this
so we can actually, you know, get what
we need over there? Where's the ship? I
thought there was a ship hitting over
here. There is one. Where it is? Where?
Where it be? Oh, there you are.
Hi. You're just chugging away, aren't
you? Well, we are going to fast forward
this so we can hopefully get that
airship over here too in order to
continue our build cuz it's going to
really suck if we just cannot continue
without any timber. You know, I guess I
can do this. I can probably set another
one of the airships for the time being
to bring some over. Lift achieved. Let's
open a trade route menu. Uh we'll take
it from New Albian because this is the
place that has the most timber right
now. So just bring a whole bunch over
right over to here. Nice. Hey mouse, you
want to work? That'd be really
fantastic. How fast this thing's
zooming. Jesus Christ.
I'm going to fast forward some more
because I want to see this ship. It has
to go all the way through this. And I
think it's possible. It has the same
size as the one that Alvahan has for the
most part. So, I think not the ship
itself, but the main harbor area
entrance,
etc. And the airship is coming in at the
same time. That's actually a really cool
scene. Oh, dude. This guy's actually
looking at it at the same time. It's
actually coming in.
That was perfect
timing.
Awesome. All right, moment of
truth. Can you go in? Yep. Awesome.
You're You're going to crash into a
whole bunch of farming vessels or
fishing vessels, but nevertheless, it
worked all the way to the back. Okay, so
what's the deal here? The horses are
probably not enough then. No, they are.
They are indeed enough at least for the
one. And now we have some more timber in
here. So the more we build these, the
more we're going to actually have to get
with the horses and whatnot. So the
administration is going to go all the
way. Even if we don't change it up for
the most part, it's going to be this
radius.
But we can have some of the regular
wheat fields over and grain fields over
in the back, which I'm not opposed to
doing in the slightest. So, I'm going to
extend this road. I'm going to bring it
somewhere to like right
here. And first thing we're going to
have to do is going to put down a
warehouse. Going to be the most
important thing. It's going to be the
centerpiece of this whole spot. And then
head over to the uh workers, right? And
we need to find the bread. There it is.
So, the grain farm grain farm is going
to be utilizing the steam motors and all
that good stuff, which is going to
require us to build a fuel depot here in
a moment. So, let's go ahead and put
this one down. We put our love into
this. I know you do, sweaty. I know you
do. And then the tractor barn we can put
down immediately. I think I'll put it on
this
side. Let's have like one little piece.
And we do indeed have enough steam
motors here to last a lifetime. So, I'm
going to put both of these into the
stockpile and then move the venty
probably over to
here. Let's go ahead and build that up.
Fields might help. Okay, woman. All
right, hold on. Hold
on. Actually, get a lot more fields than
what I anticipated originally.
like that's 135 as opposed to what it
normally is base game which is in the
200s for this. But let's go ahead and
get the fuel station underway. Now, this
is going to require us to have some
workers, which we will go ahead and
upgrade in a moment. And we can go ahead
and put the fuel station, which is going
to have a pretty decent
radius. Yeah, so far it's like getting
everywhere. So, go ahead and put this
thing like right over here. I think this
is a nice spot for it.
And now we need 75 workers. So, we can't
have you guys doing anything right now.
We're going to go ahead and upgrade a
couple of these guys hopefully soon. Uh,
the horses. Horses again. Okay, hold on.
Well, I'm bringing in some of the rain
now. So, let's get a horse training
ground set up for them. And then we're
going to build a whole second set right
next to it. That's going to look very
pretty. And you are already getting
overloaded. So, let's go ahead and put
down a small warehouse right here on the
other side of the administration
building. I think we should also have
like the occasional police office and or
police station and fire station, which
over here we're going to be prioritizing
the
volunteers. We have a volunteer fire
department right over there. We'll also
have a volunteer one conveniently
positioned right over here. when I get
more timber in. So dumb that I'm
constantly having this issue. Where's
the other one? Are you bringing the
timber? Okay, you don't need to wait.
Just Just go. Just go.
Shoot. No, you don't need to go back.
You don't need Okay. All right. Go.
Zoom. Thank you.
They take forever to load and unload
naturally. I I get it.
Let's bring that airship over here as
quickly as possible because I don't
really want to slow down this build
whatsoever. I need to get workers out
here as quickly as possible and I need
that fuel station working now. So, how
much oil do we even have in the oil
harbor? Oh, just a casual 850 already.
This thing is ridiculous. Okay, 1 second
oil is crazy. And I don't even have the
silo built up, which I don't even think
it would do anything for us unless it
provides extra goods every couple
cycles, but that's entirely up for
debate. I've never used it before, so
I'm not entirely certain. Ready to fly.
Great. Oh, wrong button. Can you deliver
all of that, please? It's probably not
even going to be all of it. Oh, no, it
is all of it. Awesome. 93 timber is just
perfect. So, build
this and let's get some of these guys
upgraded. This is where we started off
at. So, I'm going to bring these guys
in. A new milestone.
And then followed by these guys. How
much do we have
now? Well, we haven't provided them with
other things. We We can get them up kind
of close to the school, but that needs
750 of them. I need to maintain the
happy balance or start working on this
side, which is totally possible. There's
even more room over here, too, if I
really want
to get these guys upgraded. That brings
them up to 430 59. How about this? Wow.
Okay. Well, we got the workers to a a
good state, but we completely screwed
the farmers from getting that condition.
We can we can just get a whole another
set built
up. There we go. Easy peasy. And we'll
get two more over here.
Nice. Let's change their skins out so
they're at the right ones. So now we
have both of those initial conditions,
objectives, what have you, completed,
being 500 farmers and 500 workers on the
island, which is fantastic. And now I
can get this thing. Please stop. All
right, everyone. Back to it. Great.
Let's get to work. Let's get some more
of these fields operational cuz it's
going to be very, very
crucial. Got the next one over here.
We're going to build it up like this.
Okay, the tractor barn. It's going to be
looking really awesome once we have the
all the tractors running over
here. Yeah, let's tuck it in like that.
That's pretty
cool. That's the next one. Uh would be a
good measure to upgrade or update this
one like maybe twice. Oh, we're getting
the fuel in here. Awesome.
We'll have a lot of wheat fields, that's
for
sure. Get this one here. Actually, you
know what I'm going to do? I'm going to
position a couple of them.
Three like this. And then just taking a
look see at the drawing here because
there's a whole
bunch. Don't want that skin for this
one. At least for now.
And then we'll have the roads kind of go
in between each
one. Make it look a little bit more
natural. There we go. Uh get a little
overhang on that
one. Same for you. Uh you know what? Do
this to like
there. Imagine if this farmer pisses
this farmer's family off. They will
never be able to provide their harvest.
Oh man, that's where my brain goes to.
It's not like, "Oh, look, beautiful
fields, beautiful farmers. Love to see
it." No, it's going to be like, "Hey,
you want to you want to piss him off?
You're not getting your yield
out. All right, let's build these fields
to make it look all nice and pretty. Uh,
you know what? Here's this is what we're
going to do. I'm going to get rid of
this stuff in the
back. Let's fill out this spot so it
looks really nice. And then drag it as
much as we can there. This one on the
other hand is going to go along the
road. Link up there and then fill out
this spot as much as possible and bring
it further forward.
Nice. The same over here.
See what we can
do. Yeah. Okay, that's a little bit
better. I I like what it turned into,
not what it was
before. Very
pretty. Oh, you know what? Interesting
opportunity. We can probably even get a
road going straight
through like to about here to continue
building some more fields over on this
side. We should have enough fuel coming
from this thing to power all these.
Dude, this is going to be
ridiculous. How much are we even
processing right now? I I dare say it's
a bunch. 18 so far and we're consuming
one for our um our horses. But this is
because not all of them still have fuel
to
them. This guy back here is going to be
probably my favorite because uh well,
quite frankly, it's in one of the nicest
spots. I always like building these
farms right up against cliffsides like
this. I didn't think that we would only
be having these these farm fields this
small. Let me go ahead and do this. I
will put one over
here and another one right there.
And you know, when it comes to 1800, I
really do enjoy building farm fields.
For some reason, it's very relaxing to
me. So, naturally, when Mr. Major was
talking about, you know, having a bread
basket region, I was very, very excited
already. And I know that Delta's also
proposed a bread basket for New Albian,
which I'm also very excited about.
Get these about here and right
there. Gorgeous, dude. It's gorgeous up
here. Still more room. And I'm going to
exploit
it. Let's do this from here down to
about here. We're going to get another
warehouse and plop it down cuz I can
already see that horrid icon that I
absolutely despise and I don't want it
to mess around with it too too much
more. This this fuel station is in a
prime location. It's prime. I can
actually here I'll do this. Wa, that's a
lot. Okay, let's upgrade it to maximum.
We also have this guy. We'll upgrade
that a little bit. I'm seeing my bricks
go down, but then I also have these two
airships in reserve, so I will use them
if I need to.
Uh, let's get this guy like right about
here and this
here. There's also a reason why I'm
starting off with the the rain fields
and that is because I know New Albian is
having issues with
um the bread supply and naturally having
all of these built up is going to be
fantastic to get some over there.
This is going to look kind of
cool. Get the road over to this and
we'll have the
overhang. I think I might use the shift
tactic here in the event that I Oh,
maybe I don't. That's
pretty.
Yeah, that's ridiculous.
Look at that, man. You want to talk
about like probably the best
advertisement for the Bright Harvest
DLC? Here it is. This is This is what
you want. This is what you get from it.
And I tell you, it is hands down the
best DLC of this game. You cannot change
my mind. One can argue that New World
Rising was very, very good. Okay, you
have a point. But when it comes to this,
this is just so ridiculously powerful.
Bright Harvest will work from the very
beginning of the game when you start out
the very end, even if you forget about
it. That's what makes it so cool. And
not only that, it has ridiculously
awesome ornaments, too, which you can
utilize for farming settlements such as
this. Anyway, so I'm I don't know why
I'm doing a walking advertisement, but
that that there there it is.
All right, let's get the fuel into these
guys. Now, I do want to kind of move on
to another spot if I
can. Oh, I see what the issue was over
here. I Hold on. 186 bricks. I'm going
to make this a double road again because
there's going to be a airport later on
built up here. So, I want to make sure
that I get that spot linked up by a road
at least from right now. And it's going
to be a long straight one over to this
spot where the other two airships are
just big
chilling. Let's see. There's also meant
to be a little village up here, which
I'm not sure if I'm going to be building
in this particular episode. We're going
to be working on this island for a good
couple of episodes, so let's bear that
in mind as well. Let's see what it looks
like with this skin. Oh, I kind of like
this one a little bit more. I think it
[Applause]
works. Totally forgot about
it. Swap that around. Let's get this
one,
too. Very
pretty. I'll keep that one as
is. And this one. Swap it out. Uh, do it
this way. Yeah, that look nicer. Oh, I'm
always busy, duck. The field 10.
Still don't have any fuel into this
one or that one. Probably because
they're still processing. Or are they
delivering? Uh, missing goods. Still not
there. You also don't have it. I can
potentially build another road down
here. Let's probably go ahead and do
that. Build into the farm fields. Yeah,
that's really
pretty. Really pretty.
I think I will extend this one with the
shift tactic just to make it look very
pretty over
here. It's lowkey a beautifification
episode for me. So, I hope you all don't
mind. I get a little
bit too much with these farm fields from
time to
time. Uh, not all the way. How about
like maybe to about here? Yeah. And
there we go. Looks a lot nicer. So now
they're getting the fuel
hopefully. I think it should be
delivering. Yeah. So we just need the
road connection up into this spot.
Really nice. Really nice indeed. How
much are we making now? I'm I'm going to
lose it, aren't I? 45. Oh, we can do so
much better. We can do so much better
than this. It's insane. Oh, this one
doesn't even have the fuel still.
Really crazy thing about this too is
fuel stations, they're going to require
or they'll process the fuel at 15
seconds a pop, right? But then the
tractor barns process it at 5 minutes.
So you're going to have one fuel station
work for quite some time actually. So,
don't ever be worried about the fact
that you're running out cuz guaranteed
you won't you won't if you have like one
maybe two like let's look at the
production right
now. Yeah. So, like one right now is
doing just fine for all those. Maybe you
want a little bit more, but in the grand
scheme of things, this should just work
all all the time. It doesn't have to be
micromanaged too too much. That's the
beauty of this DLC.
Yeah, that one maxed out. We need some
more bricks. So, I'm going to Skies are
clear. Which what are you bringing?
You're bringing in the timber. Uh where
are you at? Are you stuck? Wait, not
there. Are you in here? Yeah. Ready to
fly. You're just uh nestled in there.
How about you get out and
then press play? Airborne and ready to
go. So, you can get over to the island
very quickly. No, you don't have to head
back. No, no, no, no. You're good.
You're good. You're good. You can go.
You can go. Thank you. Thank you very
much. Really appreciate it. We don't
need you to just be big chilling over
here. We need the stuff over there now.
There's a lot of bricks over here. I
should probably bring another airship.
You go over here. Actually, no, not you.
Well, you're already on the way. And
you're meant for this island anyway. So,
head on over. I think what I'd like to
do is have a Imperial Trade Union
position somewhere in
here. Maybe we can have it be like a
administration type office over
here, which is going to later on like
out of character. It's going to boost
these farm fields by a ton if I get the
right items into them. And some of those
items actually do increase the amount of
the farm fields and the yields provided
from them. So that can work very well
indeed. Have this set up over here. And
then as far
as banners are concerned, we're going to
have their own banners. Banner and
banner. Awesome. That's sick. I need
more. I need more of these.
Nice day for it. Yeah, it is. Hell yeah,
it is. I love building farm fields.
I have to use just regular dirt path for
now until the bricks
arrive. Very
cool. I think one more over on this side
will do.
Uh, you know what? Hold on. While I like
the placement, I think this would look a
little bit
nicer. And then in here, shift tactic.
Sure. Hell yeah, dude. That's hands down
one of the best areas I've ever made for
grain farming. And this I I hate to say
it, Patrick, it rivals Constantinople. I
I I'm sorry. I got to say it. It really
does. Ready to fly.
Uh you can cut in
line. You can deliver all of this and
even some of that and then you can fly
away. No boost to that.
Nice. A lot of work done. done. I mean,
we got the basic infrastructure stuff
done. And this being a huge freaking
bread basket is going to be even better.
So, with that local administration
already set up, too, let's go ahead and
pave the
roads. And we can either continue. I
spent a lot of time in today's episode
working on these farm fields in
particular, and they're not done yet.
They can go all the way over to here.
That's what the plan is. Actually, th
this area is going to be even more
insane. But now I'm kind of keen on
trying to find some specialists to help
us out with making these look even and
act even better because right now, I
mean, 20 seconds for some grain is just
ridiculous. Go ahead and upgrade this
one
once and then we can try to either a
expand upon the vegetable farms, which
we can do. I guess that's definitely an
idea. And I'm going to do that one, I
suppose. Uh, let's put you like right
here,
please. Oh, interesting idea. Hold on.
Interesting idea. Wait a tick. Have the
the people celebrate your leadership.
Barn right there. We can have the
fertilizer be right here. You can have a
couple like a little patch right there
in the front. That'll look kind of
pretty. And then bring it all the way to
there. Very cool. The building size is
ginormous. Build the road straight to
it. And we'll do something like this.
And I have a idea. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait a minute. Hold on. I got a
better
idea. Put this one
here. Put this one
here.
Nice. Now the island became a little bit
less attractive. But now I have to do
this. Do I? I may not need to.
This one is full yield. This one is full
yield. A farm with no field.
Uh, you know what? Head down the slope.
Yeah, head down the slope. I have an
interesting idea to pull here. Did that
screw with this one? Yeah, it did. Okay,
hold up. I'll fix it. No, no, no. Damn
it.
or
this. But this one right here. Okay. Not
get rid of its farm fields like right
here. This one on the other hand, it's
going to be kind of weird its
positioning. So, let me get rid of that
one piece and put that here. One Piece.
Great anime, by the
way. And this one.
Ooh. Wait, wait, wait,
wait. This
too. Bring him a little bit further in
the front. There we go.
You need a warehouse. You do.
And then from here, we can bring the
road straight up to
them. Nice. Fill that
out. Fill all this.
I don't think it's possible regardless
of whatever I do.
65. Yeah. Yeah, that kind of sucks.
Okay, I have to get rid of this one.
That was unfortunate. If that would have
worked, it would have been fantastic.
But and I could probably toy around with
it a little bit more and see what
happens. But in the grand scheme of
things, I'm just going to do the shift
tactic and get this whole spot to have
vegetable farms.
Which then I will get rid of this one
cuz I know there's plenty over
here. Very nice. Very nice
indeed. Very profitable, very powerful
farming settlement already. How much
vegetables are we bringing out from here
now? Cuz you know we need to make
sandwiches. We are at
40. Very nice. Okay, that's a lot of
horses there too. 56 grain. Okay. Yeah,
that's uh that's pretty substantial.
That's pretty substantial indeed. We
could probably start exporting the grain
out. And through that grain export, we
can start up like potentially having
some of the flower mills cuz look, these
guys are working right now. It's not
going to be here for the whole time.
Yeah. See, we're almost out of flour.
Uh, can we get the electrical flower
mill going? This is going to be really
good if it'll
work. Going to mess with this, but
whatever. Yeah, we have a ton of grain
over in here. So, I need to talk to Mr.
Major and Delta to see if there are any
trade agreements currently going on just
for myself to be like fully up to speed
on this. Cuz the great thing about our
community is when we have ideas and
they're bouncing between people, sky's
the limit. It's really awesome. I'm just
not told all of them. So later on I
they're like, "Oh yeah, we have this
agreement." I'm like, "Great. Awesome.
So now I can do this for you, etc.,
etc." That's what I like. So if you guys
do have ideas and you guys are talking
about like trade agreements and such,
please let me know because I want to
definitely be in the loop with all of
that. Thank you very much. Really
appreciate it. getting a lot of
vegetables out here. And there's still
even more room to make more of these. I
think just my favorite spot right now is
going to be right over here until this
whole spot in the front is going to have
a bunch of vineyards. You know what? For
the hell of it, I'm building one
already. I have to do it. I'm going to
do it. Actually, one vineyard at least.
I have
to put this one like right about here, I
think. base off of. No, wait. I'll pull
it back a little bit more. Bring it
here. We'll have a road go across. Link
it
up. Going to have to have a warehouse,
too. And we can put the warehouse right
there, I
guess. Tractor
barn. 192 fields. Let's go.
and up to the Nope, I can't do this. My
bad. Cuz I have to have roads go through
here. Really cool. And then this skin,
it's just chef's kiss, man. It's
awesome.
So once this place also has its fuel,
we're going to be getting a whole bunch
of lovely, fantastic grapes from here.
The administration, it probably is in
the nicest spot along with the banners
for this island. It's awesome. It's
powerful. It's going to be ridiculous
when it starts exporting its goods out.
What did you bring? A whole bunch of
bricks. God bless you. Awesome.
950. Yeah, I love seeing a maxed out
brick over here. I think uh no, Albahan
does not have it. Alahhan's almost maxed
on everything else except for the
bricks, which is not receiving any
anymore. Uh unless there are more
explosions, that is, which I do hope is
not the case. But it wouldn't be a
Rantis episode without an explosion,
right? An explosion, random fire. I'm
jinxing myself. I should probably do my
outro now because that's really
important, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely. So, we got a lot of work
done in the grand scheme of things. We
got the population sorted. We got the
administration going. We have the
vegetable farms and a bulk of the wheat
or the grain farms also built up. So,
we're going to be building a whole bunch
more of those. We're going to work on
the small village up there in the top in
the next episode along with getting more
of these farm fields built up over on
the right hand side of the island before
we head over to the left hand side to
get some more of the like for example
hops, potatoes, all that good stuff. So
we can export and get the bread basket
of the kingdom of Sappin back to what it
used to be and improve our relations
with them, which is extremely important
to me. We have to do so. I don't want to
have Mndde with any of the people in the
border regions anymore. As the new
regional
power, we have to do it and I'm glad to
do it. So, until next time, my friends,
thank you so much. Please consider like,
commenting, subscribing, hitting that
bell button, sharing it with your
friends. I really hope you enjoyed
today's episode. This is going to be a
really awesome build set. I'm so excited
for it, and I hope you are, too. Have a
great rest of your day, my Rantians.